[Applaudissements]
comment ça va ça fait mal toujours
vivant toujours debout toujours la
banane c'est ça c'est important merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi
vous êtes très beau en ce moment on va
en parler dans un instant parce que en
ce moment vous allez mettre tout le
monde on va voir ça dans un instant j'ai
l'impression que vous aimez tout le
monde en ce moment vous allez voir vous
allez voir que vous êtes même réconcilié
avec vos ennemis non c'est oui c'est
dans un instant d'abord où est-ce que je
saisis un petit peu parce que vous
m'avez appris j'apprends tous les jours
du grand Cyril est-ce que vous savez
Cyril que les journalistes vous surnomme
le trublion
selon quand même surnomme les gens du
PAF une expression que vous avez adoré
du coup j'ai voulu vérifier parce que
TPMP c'est quand même devenu une
émission un peu sérieuse j'ai voulu
vérifier donc si TPMP et vous vous étiez
un trublion du PAF excuse-moi va se
terminer à quelle heure bon alors vous
écoutez je voulais j'arrive je lance la
magnéto c'est quoi non mais parce que tu
me vends du temps en temps tu me prends
du temps dentaire mais oui mais pardon
de vous en grappiller quelques secondes
pardon en fait Jean-Luc Reichmann quand
tu fais ça c'est pas possible on vient
en fait
il faut la musique dessus alors salut à
tous bienvenue dans les douze coups de
midi ça va le public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut salut je suis avec un nouveau
candidat il nous vient tout droit de
Chartres voici tout de suite Richard
salut Richard salut les gens
racontez-nous ce qui s'est passé lorsque
vous aviez 18 ans alors il m'arrive un
truc de fou Jean-Luc c'est une anecdote
j'ai jamais raconté
en fait je j'étais amateur de santiag à
l'époque où c'est vrai je regardais
beaucoup Texas Ranger et en fait je
demande dans un magasin je vais devoir
dans un magasin c'est Marco de Las Vegas
le roi de la santiaggio
et je lui ai dit Marco voilà est-ce que
tu avais cette paire en 43 ok en trois
parce que vous chaussez vous même 43
et là il a Marco me ramène les
chaussures et là je vois que c'est du
carbouté c'est pas possible
mais c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
la seule émission il y a des anecdotes
mais Jean-Luc il est tellement fort que
il s'étonne de tout
l'autre
[Applaudissements]
oui donc vous êtes le trouble du PAF tu
vas recevoir
et j'ai regardé ce qui se faisait un peu
sur les autres chaînes savoir si vous
étiez vraiment fou parce que faut savoir
que je vais regarder pendant une semaine
non d'ailleurs j'ai adoré ça merci je
voulais voir ce qui se faisait un peu
sur les autres chaînes sur tout le PAF
regardez je suis lance-moi comme ça
c'est pas adoré ça toi
moi j'adore c'est le pendant ce temps là
[Musique]
la communauté urbaine théoriquement n'a
pas de compétences autour de
l'orientation professionnelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le CDE prévoit une croissance de 0,6 en
bonjour merci pour votre confiance en
cette huitième rentrée de l'orthodoxie
ici et maintenant
puisque nous allons évoquer le séjour de
Vincent Van Gogh
[Rires]
nous évoquons l'oeuvre de Saint-Nicolas
vellemirovic la Bouche d'Or Serge
[Applaudissements]
jamais entendu parler de Manhattan
moi je regarde la télé mais sur
l'ordinateur
je voulais savoir quels étaient les
natures de vos relations là la nature de
relation avec Fabrice vision non c'est
un invité un ami un avocat que j'aime
bien oui
tout ça et moi je crache pas dans la
soupe et ben alors regardez comment
Cyril n'en a rien à taper de ce que dit
de Fabrizio et respirer ensuite si c'est
quelqu'un que vous aimez bien regarde
[Musique]
les éléments il y a un prochain à côté
politique et de l'autre fois que ça
aussi un procès de société vous avez
reçu ici sergueil vous savez gagne qui a
été jeté de de LCI
on lui a même pas laisser la possibilité
de s'expliquer
est-ce que j'ai dit on les aura ces
connards qui a dit ça qui a dit ça
Patrick Fiori pauvre Patrick
la passion je suis un homme de passion
d'un fruit de la passion
on a dit dans la citation que à la
limite si mes propos avait été tenus en
salle d'audience ça va pas poser de
problème ah bah ça alors
vulgaire face à un magistrat il va être
content
incontestablement il y a un peu de ça
il a été requis contre moi trois mois
d'interdiction d'exercice quand tu vas
même pas faire tu peux pas faire de gym
ah d'accord avec moi c'est génial de pas
être d'accord avec moi parce que c'est
ça qui nourrit la démocratie c'est le
débat le débat prend on est capable
quand même
mais on est capable je m'appelle quand
même qu'on ne botte la troisième guerre
mondiale moi mon cahier ils vont
peut-être plus avoir à bouffer mais nous
on se réunit pour parler de mes tweet
merci Fabrice à tout de suite
je l'adore
Cyril on va revoir une séquence vous
avez testé il y a quelques jours les
talents du grand animateur Mathieu
Delormeau sur la fameuse séquence du
rideau alors pour ceux qui n'était pas
génial merci encore moi il y a un numéro
un qui demande qu'à sortir
Mathieu quoi
des gens que tu connais ou que tu
connais pas tu veux du bien ou du mal ok
c'est ça numéro 1 non attends
[Applaudissements]
mais une chose ne bouge pas les
chroniqueurs sont toujours autant des
langues de [ __ ] donc vous allez voir que
la séquence qui va suivre
calme-toi avec ton langage LDP vous
allez voir avec la séquence qui va
suivre que il risque d'y avoir de très
grandes tensions dans au sein des
équipes Cyril et ça va mettre un petit
dans l'ego de Mathieu Delormeau c'est le
retour du jeu qui va partir en sucette
sur la tête de Tata
le jeu de
ça va partir en sucette sur la tête de
Tata
[Musique]
l'année dernière
c'est l'expérience qui parle ils ont
trouvé des animateurs passés Daniel elle
en a vu hein
mais des critiques des deux qui ont
jamais foutu leurs pieds sur un plateau
de télé
qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire non mais
j'assume complètement là c'était raté
mais
c'était de la terre
on faisait de la télé
elle connaît les animateurs elle a vu
tout le monde hein
les chroniqueurs sont méchants entre
Cyril mais heureusement que vous vous
êtes là pour soutenir vos chroniqueurs
et pour poser les bonnes questions au
public
comment vous avez trouvé Mathieu comme
animateur les chéris
[Applaudissements]
en ce moment tout va bien TPMP
d'audience historique tous les jours
vous êtes de plus en plus beau vous
sentez bon vous êtes de plus en plus
riche que j'ai mis un peu trop de parfum
aujourd'hui non ça va même moi je me
sens non ça va
je peux encore
il va falloir que tu apprennes à papa
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la mort de ma vie
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
hors de ma vie
[Musique]
tu te calmes maintenant
c'est bon
maintenant qu'on est entre gens je
continue mon lancement
ambiance de ouf en ce moment et du coup
vous aimez tout le monde même des gens
qu'on soupçonnaient pas regardez
un connard
[Musique]
s
tchèque est très sympa aussi mais
pendant l'émission
après ces news BFM excellente Apolline
de Malherbe donc
[Applaudissements]